good morning before I begin my remarks I
want to welcome especially the parents
of our graduates I know how very special
this weekend is for you my wife and I
have shared this experience four times
that the commencement of each of our
children I know that you are nostalgic
and I know that you are bursting with
pride so let's celebrate together let me
ask the proud families and friends of
all of our graduates to join with those
of us on stage and rise to offer warm
congratulations to the yale college
class of two thousand nine
and now I'd like to ask the class of two
thousand nine in turn to reflect for
just one moment on how you came to reach
this milestone now that you've done that
one of the things that must have
occurred to you during that moment of
reflection is that there are a great
many people here today your parents
siblings relatives and friends whose
support and encouragement made your
achievements here possible I bet you'd
like to rise now and show them your
appreciation
okay we've all had a chance to stretch
now listen up when I welcomed you here
four years ago you were exhilarated but
apprehensive excited to be taking on a
new challenge but more than a little
intimidated awed by the imposing
architecture of this place by the
grandeur of this hall by the rumble of
its great organ and by the dazzling
accomplishments of your classmates who
all seem to you to belong here even if
you were not quite sure about yourself
now appropriately you feel as if you own
the place every corner of your college
every face in the dining hall is
familiar to you you have made close
friends and you have memories you will
never forget and while all this happened
the world around you was flourishing and
Yale was flourishing to building and
renovating at an astonishing pace adding
new international programs and enhancing
financial aid to make the whole
experience a lighter burden on your
families who would have imagined four
years ago that the world economy would
collapse as you leave here it's hard not
to think about this unhappy reality so
as an economist and as your president I
would like to offer a perspective on
what has happened and what it means for
you the world economy is a mess in the
United States we've experienced the
sharpest reduction in gross domestic
product in five decades and the ride is
not yet over as many of you know all too
well
jobs are scarce within the past year the
unemployment rate has increased from
five percent to eight point nine percent
and unfortunately it's more likely than
not to exceed ten percent before
declining again how do we get here not I
believe because of any inherent flaws in
the nature of the market system this is
a very important point indeed the
ascendancy of markets the relative
demise of centrally planned economies
over the past 30 years the opening of
nations to freer international trade and
investment and the rapid advance of
science and technology have led us to
unprecedented levels of global economic
growth even in the midst of this
downturn it's crucial to remember that
more people both in absolute terms and
as a percentage of the world's
population have crossed the poverty line
in the past 30 years than in any
previous period of history now the cause
of this current crisis is much less
fundamental we simply accumulated too
much debt mortgages credit card debt
corporate debt debt to support financial
speculation and government debt from
january nineteen eighty-one when ronald
reagan took office to September 2008 the
ratio of total national and debt of
total national debt public and private
grew steadily from one hundred and sixty
percent to three hundred and sixty
percent of gross domestic product as
we've seen all too painfully when
individuals have lots of debt declining
asset prices trigger delinquencies
defaults housing foreclosures personal
bankruptcies corporate bankruptcies and
even bank and solvency financial
institutions lack the capital and the
confidence to make new loans
consumers and businesses reduce their
spending company profits and stock
values fall output and income decline
and wealth evaporates because the
promise of future earning that's of
earth future earnings that supports the
valuation of assets is no longer
credible and this is where we are now
with our national wealth personal and
institutional down by more than
twenty-five percent virtually every
family in this hall has felt the impact
of this disastrous sequence of
consequences history teaches that all
credit expansions are followed by
recessions or depressions it also
teaches that recovery follows recession
the right mix of government policy can
make recovery happen faster but in the
end fast or slow we will recover as long
as the market is allowed to direct the
creative and productive forces embodied
in emerging technologies and in our
education in our educated citizens
including you in particular it will get
better it's just a question of when
meanwhile you may be wondering why you
had the bad luck to graduate now
what were you thinking I know that the
process of finding a first job has been
more difficult and more stressful for
you than for your immediate predecessors
and I know that many of you do not yet
have definitive plans for the years for
the year ahead but don't be discouraged
there are exciting opportunities waiting
for you and little reason for despair I
want to reassure you and your parents
that the investment of time energy and
money that you've made in your Yale
education will be abundantly repaid it
will be repaid in a material sense it
will be it will reward you with personal
fulfillment and most important it has
prepared you for lives of service to
family community the nation and the
world so what matters in perspective
let's remember you came here to reflect
on the world around you to expose
yourself to new ways of thinking to
encounter brilliant teachers to make use
of extraordinary library and museum
resources to develop the capacity to
think critically to express yourselves
clearly and to find both in the
classroom and in extracurricular
pursuits the passions that motivate you
you've done all this and more by
encountering classmates from 50 states
and 41 nations you have learned to
appreciate the diversity of human
talents and perspectives thanks to
Yale's extensive array of International
Programs the great majority of you have
had a chance to experience life in a
different culture you are not just four
years older by virtue of what you've
learned about the world around you and
about yourselves you are immensely more
capable of taking on life's challenges
you may doubt my conclusion at this
bittersweet moment of separation but
believe me you are ready to
leave you are
and now let's think of the exciting
possibilities that are open to you let's
start by noticing that there has been a
dramatic change in our national agenda
the most significant change of course in
nearly 30 years whatever your political
persuasion if you care about health care
education or the sustainability of the
planet now is the time to get involved
think about opportunities to engage with
these issues either in government or in
the private sector whether for-profit or
nonprofit the years immediately ahead
are going to have consequences for a
long time to come and some of you are
already responding to this call the
number of you enlisted to serve and
Teach for America the largest single
employer of yale college graduates has
more than doubled in the last two years
pretty impressive
in America's schools there are promising
signs of reform all around led by the
spectacular success of new approaches
that instill confidence and a drive for
achievement in the most disadvantaged of
our youth whether it is the charter
school models introduced by
organizations such as Kipp in New York
City and achievement first here in New
Haven or public school reforms
associated with a wide array of family
services such as in the Harlem
Children's Zone we're seeing powerful
evidence of improved performance as the
new administration and some of our
largest foundations continue to embrace
these new ideas more opportunities will
arise to engage you you might think
about following in the footsteps of Yale
graduates david levin the co-founder of
Kipp or daesh atoll the co-founder of
achievement first and contributing to
the renaissance of primary and secondary
education in the united states or think
about helping to address the challenge
of global warming in America and
elsewhere around the globe there's going
to be massive public and private
investment in new energy technologies
this will create tremendous
opportunities not only for those of you
interested in science engineering or
public policy but also for those of you
interested in business where you might
help to launch entrepreneurial clean
tech startups or make established
businesses greener and more socially
responsible in this arena you might take
as your model Yale graduates like
Francis by Nicki the executive director
of the natural resources defense council
or Kevin zinger whose company miles
electric vehicles is one of several
hoping to be first to the market with an
all-electric car suitable for highway
driving and daily commuting or perhaps
as America adopts a new and more
collaborative approach to foreign policy
you might think about building a career
that contributes to greater
international cooperation and
understanding
legions of Yale graduates before you
have pursued this noble calling from
sargent shriver the founder of the Peace
Corps to Joseph read the long time under
secretary-general of the United Nations
to career diplomats like John Negroponte
II to our current Secretary of State
Hillary Rodham Clinton perhaps the Peace
Corps or the military or Foreign Service
would be a good first step towards such
a career I was vividly reminded of the
abundance of opportunities before you
just two months ago when I convened a
group of yale alumni and Silicon Valley
to advise me on how the university might
take better advantage of new media and
carrying out its educational mission
around the table or Yale graduates who
have been instrumental in the founding
and development of companies such as
Microsoft Palm realnetworks Electronic
Arts and Facebook having come to
California fresh from a series of gloomy
meetings with Yale graduates in the New
York financial community I was simply
astounded by the unbridled optimism of
those in the new media and technology
business the prospects for investment
they told me have never been better the
cost of launching a media business
thanks to the development of widely
available software platforms and tools
is lower than ever and the possibilities
for creative engagement with the user
community are unprecedented so in
addition to contemplating a contribution
in education or energy and
sustainability or foreign relations you
might also think about new media where
Yale graduates have helped to create
entirely new forms of enterprise that
did not exist a generation ago you can
do the same I cite these specific paths
not to limit your imagination but to
encourage you to recognize that
opportunities are everywhere the
education that you've acquired here has
given you the breadth and the
flexibility
to take on the widest array of
challenges and it's given you the depth
and rigor to make a meaningful
difference wherever you choose to apply
your talent in nineteen thirty at the
darkest moment of the Great Depression
the economist John Maynard Keynes wrote
the following we are suffering just now
from a bad attack of economic pessimism
it is common to hear people say that the
epoch of enormous economic progress is
over that the rapid improvement of the
standard of life is now going to slow
down that a decline in prosperity is
more likely than an improvement pains
continue I believe that this is a wildly
mistaken interpretation of what is
happening to you to us we are suffering
not from the rheumatics of old age but
from the growing pains of over rapid
changes the increase of technical
efficiency has been taking place faster
than we can deal with the improvement of
the standard of life has been a little
too quick Keynes went on to predict that
the standard of living in advanced
capitalist countries would rise by a
factor of four to eight over the next
century he was right in the nearly 80
years since 1930 the per capita gross
domestic product in the United States
adjusted for inflation as increased by
exactly a factor of six Keynes's source
of confidence in the future was a belief
in the power of creativity and
innovation expressed through the efforts
of free well educated individuals like
you to apply scientific knowledge and
human ingenuity to the development of
new technologies new products and new
services to improve material well-being
now the potential for material advance
is no less abundant in the United States
today than it was in Keynes's
eight decades ago and what is even more
abundant today is the potential for
moving beyond material advance to a life
to a better quality of life for all
toward a healthier population a cleaner
environment a better educated and wiser
citizenry a more peaceful world women
and men of the class of two thousand
nine
you have within you the creative
potential to make a better world for us
all here at Yale you have learned to
think critically and independently you
have acquired the flexibility and the
resourcefulness to make the most of any
situation the world is all before you
choose your direction and prove that
this time of crisis is also a time of
opportunity you can do it yes you can